on parlait tout à l'heure de la hausse
des prix de plusieurs produits de
première nécessité il est une catégorie
d'aliments dont le prix est déjà très
élevé ce qui ne rebute pas apparemment
les consommateurs puisque ils sont de
plus en plus prisées ces produits il
s'agit des aliments dits allégés en
sucre ou en matières grasses
beaucoup de ces aliments vous promettent
de vous aider à garder ou à retrouver la
ligne mais attention il faut bien lire
leurs étiquettes comme nous l'expliquent
à lise gauvin et jean-marc cars 2 bat
comme vous voyez qui n'auraient pas
compris gobain j'essaye de consommer
aussi les jeux que je peux mais un peu
de mayonnaise et plus des boissons les
sodas des sodas de la mayonnaise mais
aussi de la soupe ou du real le tour
version light
cette jeune femme cherche à perdre du
poids et son nutritionniste qui l'a
conseillé la légion au moins j'ai pas
d'effet yoyo là je suis sur mon poids
le moment un tour par thebest publica et
je reprends pas comme elle un français
sur trois serait accro aux produits
allégés un marché en pleine expansion
yaourt glace plats cuisinés on trouve
des produits minceur dans tous les
rayons y compris les plus improbables
saucisson gâteaux apéritifs ou même
nourriture pour chien côté humain on
peut s'interroger sur les réels
bénéfices de ce type d'aliment qu'est ce
que ça veut dire aller j'ai allégé par
rapport à quoi
alors si vous prenez les chips ali g les
chips original étant extrêmement
calorique des chips alligier reste un
produit très caloriques
par contre une boisson light ça peut
présenter un intérêt
elliott light peut présenter un intérêt
0% de matière grasse allégé en sucre
zéro calorie sur les emballages les
appellations se suivent et se
ressemblent de quoi laisser perplexe le
consommateur lambda
en fait on est nous un petit peu devant
une offre
parfois incompréhensibles parce que
souvent on va avoir un produit qui dit
qu'il a moins de sucre et en fait il a
effectivement moins de sucre mais à la
place du sucre on a mis du gras et donc
il est plus calorique qu'un que le
produit référent donc il faut faire
vraiment très attention et lire les
étiquettes lire les étiquettes une
précaution dont se passe la plupart des
consommateurs
suffit de regarder les calories
d'arrière je pense on la proposition
il est fière qu'on me lâche et des
produits nets non
je fais confiance aux marques mais
qu'elle met un light je suppose que tout
va bien
et pourtant à y regarder de plus près
les produits minceur ne sont pas
forcément plus léger ces céréales de
régime au chocolat par exemple au moins
de sucre que la recette pour enfants
mais un peu plus de gras et au final le
même nombre de calories dernier piège à
éviter la surconsommation le produit
light et déculpabilisant on a donc
tendance à en manger deux fois plus